[音楽]
me
静岡つで購入専門店をやってますクレアールの家だと言いますよろしくお願います
今日私は話そうとして持っているのはこの勝つとわーということです
だがこんなことを話しするかというと
私はた商売やってて非常に感じるのがよくあの売れるものに価値があるということを
言われてきたんですけども
私がやってるコーヒーの中でこのおいしいということに価値がないんだろうかと
そういう思う場面に何回も遭遇することがありまして
でその中でこうまあさっき紹介していただいたかポンエッセンスという国際員協会
なんか開かれる
中で感じたことを今日は話そうと思っています
皆さんのお手元に多分入り口であの服を小さい袋白か黒の袋を若されたと思うんです
けどもそれをちょっと開けて封を切っていただけますか
この中にはのコーヒー入ってますねえ
今話をしました国際線堺のカップ sns の中で黒い袋を手にしている方は
グアテマラという中米の小さな国の審査会で去年3位になったままであと後ろの袋は
ブラジルで去年になったままです
封を切っていただいてな花の香りをぜひ撮ってみてください
この香りをとっていただくと
今までのコーヒーとはちょっと違うっていうかそういう香りがすると思います甘いん
花という活動んというか
いかがでしょうか
ねにまあのこちらのスライドの方に出ていますけどもコーヒーというのはまず昨日3
ですこの白い花がこれコーヒーの花です
ちょうどあの水鉢なんかも止まっているんですけども
だいたいこれで9ヶ月くらいかけて鼻からは赤い実がなってその赤い実の種がコーヒー
として日本で販売されてます
茶色いためがなるのではなくてあれも私たちがこの日本に入ってきたの
グリーンビーンズっていうくらいなんで緑色をしたマメなんですけどもそれを焙煎して
それで
茶色にして販売しております
で皆さんが飲めるようになるまでだいたいこの花の状態から飲めるようになるまで延べ
200人くらいの人が珈琲店が多数あっていると言われます
その中で美味しいコーヒーを作るというのはどういうことかというのが私たち日本人は
よく美味しさは好みだからなんだかって言ってその美味しいってことを価値として認め
ないような非常に認めづらい
風潮があるんですけどもそれがちょっと変わってきているということで話を進めていき
ます
で1つの例なんですけどもあの今皆さん多分コンビニでコーヒー召し上がるとことある
かと思うんですけども
今だいたい公民いうコーヒーとは一般100円くらいで売ってますねちょっと前まで
120円から130円とは150円
そのくらいまでの範囲で売っていまして最近では一番高いところで1杯300円って
いうのを持ったりです
んですけどもコンビニによってはそんな高いの売れないからうちは置かないっていう
ところもあるらしいです
この1敗が100円になったか物を見るときにあの
もしかしたら皆さんやすくなった飲みやすくなったりあの買いやすくなったから良かっ
たと思うかつ人の方もいらっしゃるかと思うんですけども
私たちが見た時にあのコーヒーを1杯120円を100円にするって事はそうに10円
っていうのはコーヒー豆の件かなんです
喧嘩を削るということですだいたいコーヒーをのものにカップとか砂糖とかあのミル
クってほとんど価格そんなに変わらないでだいたい一番母の曲誰だ水のは高機能ので
その20円30円を削るということはどういうことだって言うと
1杯あたり20円30円があれば少しや良い豆が支えたのがそれで全く使えなくなった
その分が
全部線三者にしわ寄せが行くみたいな年さを作っています
ねコーヒーを作る国っていうのは非常に高
貧しい国が多くて
でコーヒーというのはニューヨークで先物市場がありましてそこで取引をしてます
その中でえっ
価格が決められていてまぁ先物取引なのが非常に科学の団交下がありましてまずそうだ
高いときはまだいいんですけども安くなりますと非常に好戦三者に全部幸せが入って
まぁコーヒーを作り続けられない
それからもう農業やってられないみたいな連鎖が始まりましてねそう
いうのをどうにかしたいということで国連が中心になったその貧困国対策プロジェクト
ってのは約20年前くらいに
広げました
それを引き継いでアメリカの要件を法人が始めたのこの国際審査会のかポンエッセイの
ストーリーです
今スライド変わりませんこれらの割烹べくセンスの様子なんですけども
あのこちらの一番上にあるのは変票回で1位になってブラジルで1位になった人はの
生産者喜んでる写真でこのこちらは右側これかプレゼンツとは関係ないんですけども
今年ボリビアに行ってきて生産者がまあこういう赤い実を積んでいるこれらのコーヒー
のみで
ですね猫の車月のコーヒーの実をてっぺんにとっている生産者の写真ですとか
こちらの割烹別のその現地のサポーターが並んでます
でこういう雰囲気の中で審査会を進めていきます
猫の生産国です審査会をやるっていう意味なんですけども
意外と皆さんやっともうかもしれないですねも作ってること自分たちが作ってる物って
どういう汗なのかどういう評価をされるのかっていうのは案外知りません
これもしかしたら日本の農家の方も結構共通してるんじゃないかなと思うんですけども
自分の作ってるのが一番おいしいと思っているのか後全く逆に食べたことがないだとか
意外とそういう方多い
んですけれどもそれをあの用水栓産地と生産者と消費国を結びつけて自分の作ったもの
がどういうふうに客観的に評価されるのか
それをわかってもらおうというロジェクトです
でこれ生産者は講義作ってる人はだれでも参加できます
で審査員っていうのはあの最初はこう
オブザーバーとして参加してでまあこいつちゃんとした評価ができるって認められると
次の年から tin sign として国際審査員として登録されます
でこの審査員であると開催国例えば私なんか日本からこのグアテマラブラーてるまでい
くっていうのはその多くの費用ってのは全部自費で払っていきます
でですから要するにこのプロジェクトに何か協力する医師の人にある人達はあの自分
たちの国からお金を払って来てくださいというプロジェクトです
でエントリー1か国アトリエントリーだいたい300種類ぐらいのコーヒーが出ます
あのよく日本の方が勘違いしてるんですけども珈琲っていうのは例えばブラジルとか
コロンビアとかそういう種類があるんじゃなくて
ブラジルコロンビアて一つの国でその中でいろんな農家の人がコーヒーを作ってます
その例えばブラジルなぜコロンビア
形でんだいたい300ぐらいの豆が集まってきて誰でも参加できるこれは自分が良い
コーヒーがペンを300くらい集めてそれを国内新装して国際審査まで引き上げていき
ます
これが審査会の様子ですでコーヒーの評価方法っていうのはカッピングというのをやる
んですけども
ちょっと見にくいかもしれないんですけどもうこのカップの中に粉を入れてあとお湯を
注いでそれを評価するだけの方法がコーヒーの味というのは強化します
猫の評価方法っていうのはもう国際的なものでコーヒーをあ
耳を評価するときはこれで評価するっていうふうにも決まっていますので
日本人がこれをオカシイって言ってもそりゃ駆虫挟むようなよとなる強化方法ではあり
ません
これに代打300ぐらい農家がエントリーしてそれをこのカッピングというの9000
回ぐらい繰り返して
それで評価をしています
ねあの評価方法オンをどういうことをするかというとこの左側にあるのはこの
カッティングシートと言って
味を
八つに分けて評価するシートを作ってます
猫のプログラムのいいところっていうのを2つありまして
この評価応報が恋しいとにもで点数化するという非常にわかりやすいところとあと
透明さえこのプロジェクトはどういう風に
どこの国の誰がこういうものをコーヒーを作ってそれをどこの国がどんな人たちが
集まってきてその人たちがこういう点数で評価をして
でそれをなんてに評価されてこれがタップ高額選手として選ばれたっていうのだいたい
20から30ぐらいあるんですけどもそれが公開ネット上に公開されて
でそれを誰がいい
小国で落とし誰か買ったかってのは全部わかるようになってます
ちょっと難しい形になっちゃったんですけども要するに良いものを作る生産者で良い
モノを作る人がこの国ここにいてそれを書いたから人が同9位のここにいるってね非常
によく分かりやすくなりましたで今までっていうのはあの
全くそれがわからない状態のときはいいものがほしくても誰
から何を買っていいのかわかんないからもうどうしようもないった状況だったのが
そういう透明性が出ることによって私たちが欲しいと思うものいいものは彼が持ってん
だっていうのを
それがわかるようになってきましたでこの割烹学生ですっていうのは味だけを評価し
ますこのカッティングシートでですからあの
なぜかよく私たちはもう例えばね
有名な農園だとか有名な政治家との仲がいいだとかそんな感じのところが評価されも
なんてことは一切ありません
私たちの目の前でてくるときこの1回戻りますけども
このカップに入った時はもう全て粉の状態です実際何の情報もなくただ挽いた粉が出て
きてそこにお湯を入れてそれで強化してくれということになります
だいたいこれでええ
上位その割烹ぼっちゃんですというふうに入った20分から30分ってネット
オークションになる語るんですけども
その時の落札価格っては先ほど言いましたニューヨーク先物市場の普通の取引の科学の
最低で2倍で最近では高いものや60倍ぐらいになって落札されています
でその落札価額の83%が生産者に還元されるといいます
でこの話をするというかのフェアトレードじゃないのっていうフェアトレードだのって
言い方されるんですけども
あのフェアトレードなんかでも一般的に村生産者に83%販売価格の883%が還元さ
れるということは少ないという話です栄光の割烹
夏のですがその
落札されたものがどういう効果を高値で落札されたものがどういう効果を生むかという
とこれはあの
コロンビアで初めて開催されたカップオウムエクスセンスで1位になった人が落札され
てお金で建てた家なんですけども
日本にいるとわかんないかもしれないんですけども生産者の方っていうの結構穴蔵
みたいなベッドもないような
小さい所に住んでいることが多くてそれが高校いう立派な a 進めたりとかこうやっ
ていっぱいお子さんもいるんですけども
こういう子供を大学にやれるようになったとかあともう一つ
もうこの審査会に出品するの最後にコーヒーをか値段ないからコーヒーを作るの
やめようと思ってたらちゃんと自分の作るものが良いものが評価されたから
もう1回コーヒーを作る勇気が湧いてきたと言ってちゃんとした農場を作るようになれ
たりそういった人が出てきています
後もう一つこれすごいなと思ったんですけども
ゲームのをスクール美味しいものを作るためには
子供に教育が必要だってことに気づいてくれたんですね
例えばあの日本てもも率は非常に低いですから文字水すぐ読めるだろうっていう感覚な
んですけども
青山国の人ってもう率が非常に高くて半分ぐらい絵とか文字が読めないなんて普通に
ありますから a ねそういうところでまぁそんなか
学校なんか行くんだったら自分たちの農作業を手伝いみたいに言ってたのが
要するに自分たちが良いものを作ってそれを継続させるために子どもに教育をさせ
なきゃいけないっていうことで子どもをいかに工学校にあるか
あの仕事は手伝いに行ってちゃんとケア学校に行って勉強しろと
ってそうするとそういうふうにんの力が地域に生まれてくると地域の学校っていうと
を大事にしなければいけないとかそういう動きになってたのはすごいなと思っています
あとた蛇行は言ったもののなかなかこれをさっき言いましたよねあの
値段高いですですからその価値観お値段だけにしていくと例えば abc分析何かやっ
てこれは濡れないって言ったらあの
すぐこの商品で排除されて売れなくなっちゃうんですよタダだからそれをじゃあどう
やってお客さんに理解してもらうかその活動は今度日本とか
消費国では非常に大切になってきますで特にこの
コーヒーの味っていうのは
日本っていうよりもやっぱり恭順が世界になっておりましてそれを学ぶ必要があります
なぜこんなことを言うかというと日本っていうのはやっぱりコーヒーの商品の歴史が
短いですし一番近い戦争に負けたりしてコーヒーの輸入が途絶えちゃった事件もあり
ますねで1回輸入が途絶えた後入ってきたコーヒーてないん
だから振り返ると非常に広い品質のコーヒーが入ってきてそれをいかに売るかっていう
日本で売るかっていう努力をした先人たちの努力ってがありましてその中であの語られ
た味っていうのは国際的に評価されない味のことが多くてそれを私自身も勉強しなけれ
ばなりませんでしたっっで
とそういうのを知るためにやっぱり自分たちで足を運んで生産者の現状とかそういうの
を実際肌で自分たちが知ってそれかそれをお客さんに訴える必要がありましてその
勉強っていうのはをの勉強とその味の神道って言うんですがそれは非常に苦労してい
ます
で私たちはこの自分たちの中でまあそういうたまたま
ネットが発達していった中でそういう仲間を募って今ここに後ろに15人くらい集まっ
ているんですけれどもそういう仲間と一緒に勉強会やって
なかなかなぜさんの個人商店の集まりなものですから勉強すると言っても苦労するん
ですけれどもそれを15年くらい続けまして
それであの世界基準点ですかそういったものを学んでいきました
それをお客さんに伝えるように努力してますおかげでこうも今15人の内12年ぐらい
は割烹別のですねー
国際品評会に出てまして例えば日本私たちの仲間に入ってきた豆ってのは自分たちで
あの
評価をするだけでもうカップ音楽センスの国際審査ができるねみたいなそんな感じに
なってきました
そういう美味しさを一つのカス官として
認めてそういう中から直接生産者とのっ
つきあいが始まってそのなんと今まではそのただ値段だけって言うか力美味しいものを
から生まれてくるこの人のははから生まれる
異常 new
まあ楽しいというかもう素晴らしい価値観っていうのを学ぶことができています
今日はそれを一つ訴えたいと思いません
ありがとうございましたはい
[拍手]